[Music]
and graduation gone wild news Oh does
that meet edit and stuff college today
goodbye mushiya from all who never leave
you know they got this crew called the
Gurkhas whatever you oh yeah at the
cigars the military they're like a
Nepalese special unit that the French
trained and they're [ __ ] wild it's
kind of like the net believes like maybe
seal dude where were you or hope you had
that article oh yeah commercial forces I
was here parents broke out in a brawl
what and the wire at a high school
graduation over saved seats oh that is
not the time and place to do anything
like I'm ghetto Asian it's not about you
it's about the graduating class hold on
baby graduate then see usually at a good
classical I don't want to do I want it
to be at a very awkward school Dhabi
tight I'm not sure ghetto behavior but I
can tell you that the graduation was
held in a church oh oh my god no ghetto
I'm pretty sure that's pretty ghetto man
that's some ghetto as [ __ ] I will tell
you though if anybody out there grew up
in a Korean church Church abroad or
quite combination for real Oh
looking like colonies politics and [ __ ]
ever I [ __ ] told you those that do
that [ __ ] knocked out the pastor like
during all the [ __ ] sermon to do
knock the guy out [ __ ] Koreans like
fighting so much I don't know I don't
understand what it is about our culture
well actually you know I kind of do
because our country has been [ __ ] over
quite a lot so it's s there's a lot of
like ill-will like nobody is going to
[ __ ] with me no more yeah or I'll take
advantage of you first before you do it
to me oh but then like to each other
though will they do it to anybody it's
just that history though it's not an
excuse but it's kind of like if you look
at the history of our people it's just a
lot of us getting our [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
by everybody it sucks being in the
archipelago
like we were like the possession of
China
whenever [ __ ] would go down they would
send our people first to go die [ __ ]
like that so kind of set in Japan
[ __ ] [ __ ] this in the ass too pretty
bad
so our just have a huge gaping [ __ ]
uh are you tolling our heart down so
feel bad for Korean people but now we've
ruled the world of kpop and BTS yes oh
this cake plays in Arlington Tennessee
I'm just going to show you how the video
I think it's pretty ponies all intent
Annesley
in the name of Jesus Christ give me my
seat Oh Oh fighting a man is a guy a
girl she there a while
oh damn she's strong
see this dancer dude oh is that a lady
or a god a big one hello
that is ghetto I better she does fight
on yeah Oh she'll I'm not taking down
[Applause]
the motion drop e oh he is something
yeah he said I'm going to show you can
visit Korea even though I don't have to
even in force even worn by law
enforcement to shut up
awesome yeah yo that lady though she was
a little on a pocket though like you see
her my people are trying to like calm
her down like tell her stuff she just
kept swinging at everybody and everybody
was kind of controllers just going at it
it's costing smoke math dude nothing
she wasn't doing that a name of the Lord
I said damn yes I just my favorite thing
in the whole thing is this ladies react
a half a day that's a ball and a stress
and you know to be completely honest
with you I don't know why people want to
go to graduations that boring us
[ __ ] a lot of hell along god damn it
man my mom always wanted me to walk I'm
like man lady it's gonna look the same
please don't be very proud of you I know
but I'm just I'm fine
siding with it I just like how in the
beginning of graduation like whenever
like everybody's names gets called in
the beginning like everyone just like
clapping and they have a whole bunch of
energy and in the middle is just like
yellow straight up so I just went to a
CSU Long Beach's graduation and God made
you talk about some of the most
unenthusiastic human beings people are
walking up there just like this yeah
it sounds like damn y'all give a [ __ ]
about your children what else [ __ ] you
guys don't give and their graduation was
extra fast to like literally the speech
was like it was this guy he looks like
so everybody stand up and take a selfie
there's going to be three types of
graduation selfies and he's like making
jokes about it the Knicks are calling
people up to get their buggy diploma or
the little roller pen awesome it was
just really quick it out like wow this
cool really doesn't give a [ __ ] about I
think my favorite thing of going to
graduations other people's graduations
since a kid was the [ __ ] things that
people did in the crowd like the beach
ball thing yeah disruptive I don't even
know if they do that anymore they did do
that at mine at all
there was no beach ball this was a guy
that she wanted a [ __ ] and pass it
around and then people are trying to
give a speech and [ __ ] yeah but I think
they let rats root loose and it all goes
like straight up though the the the guy
who was announcing the names [ __ ]
amazing he had like the announcer voice
and every like it's like Hispanic manky
[ __ ] nail back yeah yeah yeah but can
I be there's like people doing it like
you're like I know you what that's tight
because it'll be impressive if he did
leave it like the Japanese days like on
point
this dude practical in it dude yeah guy
was dope maybe that would have major
cultural names I know if I'm all talking
at home I think it was like doing like
crazy [ __ ] was bowing and [ __ ]
that's time I don't think I've ever seen
any girl should go down and imagination
I do that like or in a charge that size
they should be one of those mega
churches do yeah what would you guys do
if that was like your mom I'd be so
embarrassed
I'd be so mad you know the mom fighting
yeah I'll just be like did you win you
win a back her up I mean if there's
other guys your mom what if I she's so
sweeping up here on that [ __ ] flower
petal dude falling into a little pond
you know my mom you guys know my mom
really softly she's a complete opposite
of me my sister was I think 18 she's
working at a video store this is how old
it is there's [ __ ] a video store and
my mom was dropping her off at work and
there was a car waiting for a parking
space and that car thought my mom was
going to take it a little bit you know
that my mom was just pulling over to let
my
check it off and then I was a guy and a
girl the guy is the girl in the
passenger seat girl gets out starts
yelling at my mom from what my sister
tells me they're telling a my mom so how
you [ __ ] [ __ ] this is my space like
what the [ __ ] oh you can't just come up
and try to take it or everyone's like oh
sorry I shouldn't drop my daughter and I
guess the girl was so enraged she just
went through the window because it was
like a crack open and then she just
pulled my mom's hair oh my sister was
like what the [ __ ] am I your sister in
the car she was ready your sister was
already walking away and then someone
said one of her co-workers like oh
you're someone yelling at your mom and
more messing around that's when the lady
was pulling my sister's hair like this
long your mom - my mom's hair and then
my she's like oh well no so she just
started whaling on this girl like in the
parking lot in front of her job and then
I want to do would your mama fighter is
you just know my mom know you know my
mom she had nobody at that time old your
mom is a swedish lady I've ever been
another stop and then my sister was just
like like tearing up her mouth she had
braces so she was like bleeding all the
crows being all them I wouldn't show her
and her boyfriend or whoever that guy
was really trying to have him stop and
she started whaling on guys - I bet she
was bleeding all over the place
mister severed their heads and headed
like this try and tell her mom have she
on me dad that's crazy who would ever
hit your mom dude no she doesn't even
have a attitude issues like crazy stuff
I can't imagine anybody getting involved
I know this is not wait for someone else
pulled on in mom's there
I hope they're not robbing [ __ ] them up
about my hair
I want to see you fight first and it
sounds I don't I think you wouldn't
listen [ __ ] - sir well she's pregnant
also they're different I wanna see you
fight with plate at first and then I
jump in wait you wanna pregnant first
what the [ __ ] wrong with these you're
kidding I'm not
[ __ ] premature ejaculate i'ma see
what happens and of course if you can't
have it on the be there imma be there
like that making your stomach and [ __ ] I
would even have to happen
you should getting slapped around a
mouth let's see what Jill does don't
kick come why what I want to see this
don't lie I'm an unruly [ __ ] okay
you are you you're not pregnant right
now the kids already out he's doing my
tech wand oh yeah like that you're like
gonna die I don't know you went to like
some little quick spawn [ __ ] I'm the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that comes up sup [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you doing in my spot
get the [ __ ] out my spot
[ __ ] your ass up I don't know I don't
think I haven't like that
confrontational but I think I've even
grabbed the trinket on interface oh uh I
think another turkey interface oh I
probably I promise you Solange on her I
don't think I don't think I could say
anything mmm I like that thank you for
that response I think it depends if they
touch you or not while she's sewing some
[ __ ] at my face
that's very true oh I mean I don't think
it's yeah I don't think it's worth
anything I'd be like all right well
you're weird but you're just like no
goal and like grab it aquafina a new
leaf yeah I mean cuz boy she to me like
you unless she's doing some [ __ ] to you
or you guys may be like oh yeah follow
us on Instagram so you could spy on us
like a sneaky perverted neighbor because
you know I always post sexy photos for
the last video click over here
[Music]